Today, I want to extend my best wishes to all who are celebrating Nowruz...
...here in the United States and around the world.
This is a holiday for the Iranian people to spend time with friends and family,...
...to reflect on the extraordinary blessings that you enjoy,...
...and to look forward to the promise of a new day.
After all, this is a season of hope and renewal.
And today, we know that this is also a season of promise...
...across the Middle East and North Africa,...
...even as there are also enormous challenges.
I believe that there are certain values that are universal,...
...the freedom of peaceful assembly and association,...
...the ability to speak your mind and choose your leaders.
And what we are seeing across the region...
...is the insistence on governments that are accountable to the people.
But we also know that these movements for change are not unique to these last few months.
The same forces of hope that swept across Tahrir Square...
...were seen in Azadi Square in June of 2009.
And just as the people of the region have insisted...
...that they have a choice in how they are governed,...
...so do the governments of the region have a choice in their response.
So far, the Iranian government has responded by demonstrating that...
...it cares far more about preserving its own power...
... than respecting the rights of the Iranian people.
These choices do not demonstrate strength, they show fear.
For it's telling when a government is so afraid of its own citizens...
...that it won't even allow them the freedom...
...to access information or to communicate with each other.
But the future of Iran will not be shaped by fear.
The future of Iran belongs to the young people,...
...the youth who will determine their own destiny.
The young people of Iran,...
...carry within you both the ancient greatness of Persian civilization...
...and the power to forge a country that is responsive to your aspirations.
Your talent, your hopes, and your choices...
...will shape the future of Iran and help light the world.
And though times may seem dark, I want you to know that I am with you.
Let this be a season of second youth for all Iranians.
A time in which a new season bears new life once more.
Thank you. And aide shoma mobarak!